[Music]
[Applause]
he's Justin Tuck he has two more Super
Bowl rings than you do former defensive
end third round pick out of Notre Dame
and now look at him he is a managing
director in private wealth management at
Goldman Sachs okay show
off what's going on Dan how are you
great great um the importance when you
finish your career and decide what you
want to do when did you want to go into
wealth
management um I think I always wanted to
go into Finance I think um you know
Gears of playing in in the NFL and being
NFL locker rooms and and watching some
of the struggles some of our players had
with u their own personal wealth what to
do with etc etc we all know the the
history of um the documentary around
broke and and all of that stuff so I
always wanted to be in finance but I
think when I thought started thinking
about where I could have the biggest
impact especially for our players um you
know athletes and entertainers uh having
more representation in that space that's
what kind of led me to be more on the on
the advisor side and private wealth so I
think it was it was later in my kind of
football career that I I actually start
thinking about that all right so you go
to Notre Dame get a degree there
and then you have to go back to business
school yes so you go to Wharton do you
have to go to classes there most
definitely most definitely and plus it's
in Philadelphia so no one likes me
[Laughter]
so it's tough okay but you're sitting in
classes with people and you know like
yeah just regular students huh yeah I
mean listen I um the first couple weeks
there are tough because a lot of the
professors there had had adopted the the
identity of um being Eagles fans so a
couple couple classes I just walked in
with my Super Bowl rings and put it on
their desk and just kind of kind of
tried to to level set you know how this
semester was going to go um but it was
tough I mean it was it was the toughest
thing about it was getting back to
getting used to using that side of your
brain before I mean obviously I I went
to a big time School academic School in
Notre Dame but it been 12 years since I
even you know had to deal with the
rigors of studying for these tests and
being up at you know 2 am with these 26
year old kids who had you know had
internships at the golden Sachs of the
world and and they were they were in
Prime shape where I had some some
getting getting off from behind the
eightball in a lot of situations in that
regard but you know two years at Warden
was very uh you know constructive as far
as was getting me that that that that
that Foundation I needed to go into this
financial world what do young football
players well young athletes make what
what's the biggest mistake they or you
you see a Common Thread with these these
kids I think not just athletes in
general but a lot of my clients um you
know luckily they you know very wealthy
so it doesn't really take in
consideration but spending is always the
issue um um you know I think I think
when especially athletes when we we
start making money most of us come from
situations where we haven't had um you
know that type of money haven't had the
experiences with that money I think a
lot of times you we're all ego Maniacs
right we all want to compete and have
the the biggest house or the biggest car
or the nicest clothes or go on the best
vacations and we all feel like you know
because we
are have this some level of Fame we gota
buy private etc etc right so I think the
biggest thing is helping guys understand
that you know I know this is your first
time you know you're new to making this
type of money but this money does not
last long especially when you think
about the fact that you know NFL or
athletic careers are still so much more
short than you know that of a
professional right you know I was
blessed to play 11 years and I retired
when I was 32 years old about to turn 33
that's a lot there a lot of life left in
that so you know I the first thing I
think about clients is just like let's
get the right budget for you and your
you know your um your situation and and
try
to spin the right way I guess we're
talking at Justin Tuck he won two super
bowls with the Giants now he works at
Goldman Sachs managing director in
private wealth management what's it like
on Monday morning when you go into the
office and I'm going to guess your
co-workers want to talk
football uh yeah well lately it's been
very tough last year was a lot easier um
um you know obviously luckily it's a lot
of Giants fans around my my office and
um they they know at this point now when
I want to talk football and when I don't
um but I think early in my career
Goldman I got a lot of silly and what I
would call dumb questions I know people
say there is no such thing as a dumb
question there are some dumb questions
um like what what would you get asked
where you go that's a dumb question a
man you put me on the squad I I've
gotten so many like you know I've gotten
some of my analysts ask question like
you know I don't know why did why did
Eli choose number 10 or um do you do you
hear a crowd when they're yelling I'm
like yeah my ears work pretty well like
you know just silly things like you know
um you know you know how does it feel a
sack of quarterback or you know and I'm
I'm I'm sure I've gotten some Dumber
questions than those I just can't think
of any right now but you know I think
now I spent the last six years educating
most of these um you know MIT grads that
know nothing about football I've
educated them enough where they they
they're asking some legitimate questions
and um you know at least I'm doing my
duty as for as like hopefully I'm I'm
building the NFL's brand you know one
Analyst at a time nice
so see I would have I figured somebody
would say what's it like to hold Tom
Brady in your arms you know
[Laughter]
something how many how many times did
you hit him in those Super Bowls
hit um I had four sacks and yeah I saw
stat like it was something crazy us as a
team at first Super Bowl I think we we
on dropback passes we we actually hit
him 70% % of the time or something like
that right it was it was it was
unbelievable the fact that we played
that well against such a a quality
competitor and quality team um but yeah
I mean like he everyone asking me the
question like what's your favorite
quarterback to sack and I always tell
them all them takes the same but I think
I think with
Tom it was such a big moment so it's
gonna it's gonna it's gonna feel a
little different just because of the
Super Bowls but um yeah we hit him we
hit him a lot and I I try always when
people ask me that question to give a
lot of credit to him because I've seen
quarterbacks fold I've seen we we those
teams we had the Giants we had the
opportunity to have some really really
great defensive line efforts where we
hit quarterbacks a lot and I've seen
quarterbacks in some ways give up none
of that was in Tom and he fought to the
end I think if you remember the last two
throws in those two games he threw the
ball over you know 65 70 yards in the
air um after getting pummeled all game
so I give him a lot of credit I've seen
I've seen quarterbacks not want any part
of it and uh he he stayed there to the
end so that's why he's probably going to
go down as the best quarterback if not
best football player ever I remember
Michael Strahan saying a few years ago
that you can have sometimes have more
respect for somebody with the punishment
that you would Dole out and they hung in
there and he said look I respected Tom
even more because we hit him with
everything that we possibly had and it
and I'm talking about some big hits some
some some right up the right up the you
know in between the one and the two hits
uh that we like to say and like you know
I can't I can't give Tom too much credit
without giving my personal quarterback a
lot of credit too because that game was
very similar to Eli and San Francisco if
you remember um you know Alden Smith
Justin Smith that defense that in
Candlestick that night that that that
that Eli got pbl I I remember seeing it
looked like it was a cartoon character
where you know when like like Tom and
Jerry or somebody get steamrolled and
like you see their print in the ground
it seems like that CU you know
Candlestick was really soft as well so
like seeing him get like peeled you know
peeled off of the ground after Alden or
Justin or or whoever else had hit him
that was one of those games where I was
like man Eli the Dopey Eli I got a lot
of respect for that guy after that game
because he got P up and obviously with
Tom and those Super Bowls the same thing
wait wait you called him Dopey Eli yeah
we always call Eli Dopey why because
he's
Dopey
okay how did he react I'm sure I'm sure
I'm sure he's gonna have a comeback for
that but uh yeah don't be
Eli it was it's funny because Eli
regardless if he was if he was having a
game where he was throwing four
touchdowns and 400 yards or he was
having a rough game his facial
expression was always kind of the same
so we just called him Dopey Eli if you
could sit down with any person in
America to talk Finance to talk
business who would it
be Finance or business there two okay
let's let's do
business business
um wealth management you're talking
wealth management with any person in the
world
um
that's tough I'm I'm blessed to have so
many great people around me I think if I
was talking wealth management Finance in
general
um it would be Paul to the
Jones a mixture of Paul T the Jones Ken
langone
and I mean Buffett those three would be
very high on my list I mean I would you
know
that point
um business woo
um that's
tough I mean honestly it'll probably be
somebody that has constantly like
started things and created
things
um like Elon Musk is Elon Musk that's
what I was thinking I know he's
controversial a little bit but that's
what I was thinking because he's he's he
is he's brilliant and he's created
things over and over again right it's
it's not like you know you see a lot of
times in business you see guys who you
know make a a huge Splash with one
company or one you know idea he's he's
done it over and over again and I don't
see anything stopping him I mean like I
was just I was just looking at SpaceX
and there new valuation of50 billion
dollar right it's just I mean it's it's
it's screw MCD duck type numbers with
that guy so um yeah I I would pick him
up there very high great to talk to you
glad you're doing well thanks for
sharing the stories there all right man
listen Dan is always a pleasure uh
appreciate you having what do you
benching
now a lot less than I used
to all right but probably the most in
the Goldman Sachs office you know what
we got some we got some we got some
weekday Warriors in the in the if I got
challenged and you gave me like two
weeks yeah I would do it but like I you
know I tell people all the time I used
to get paid a lot of money to work out
now I'm working out because I'm old so
it's different like the amount of weight
I put on the bar now is so so
drastically lower than what it used to
be I just want to I just want to be able
to say that I worked out so um and in
some ways look good in the bathing suit
that's about it he's Justin Tuck won two
super bowls with the Giants and
currently the managing director in
private wealth management Goldman Sachs
thank you Justin